go explode you like see your characters
going in future what you see happening
short Pat answers you're not dying go to
season 5 but for me it really has it's
been it's always if there's something
about the show it's a surprise because
we don't know so so far the writers have
kept us kept me guessing and when it
sometimes you think awesome sometimes
you think what and but either way it's
it's exciting and it keeps you on your
toes so may just just it's broke don't
fix it so I'm happy to go for whatever
ride that this guy's takes me up
I want Lourdes to be happy you know I
think she's gone through it kind of
Shiite and I think that she deserves
some quality good times I'm sure we've
got a pretty interesting little new
dynamic coming up yeah upcoming season
so playing that through the fourth
season was fun challenging it's not at
times just because I guess you can you
can get very comfortable in what your
character is and you sort of see the
trajectory of where you're going and
then when they drop something like what
they have coming for the two of us and
obviously they can't talk about it stuff
I think it is in the and you know you
know so when you have something like
that happen it's it's it's fun because
it redefines what that relationship is
I'm pretty excited to see where that
would go and to the fit season because
obviously we know what's going on in the
fourth spoilers crazy
Aleksey who you last saw as our leading
half alien half sister who say she comes
six or seven last time we saw her
some crazy stuffs happening that with
her yeah she's not sure completely sure
she's she's one of the
yeah sure as like in every previous
season the scope of the show is getting
larger you know in season one we were
the second mass the rebellion 100 people
in the East Coast and then every seasons
gotten progressively larger our
knowledge of the mythology has God has
increased so this season is no different
one thing I really like about this
season is that with it being the fourth
season we've seen each other interact
with the two or three people we usually
interact with the most over and over and
over so this season starts off with us
separated into four groups and so we're
seeing people paired with other people
that you haven't really seen these
interactions and to me that was that was
really fun to get to see it wasn't so
much with my character I'm so excited
it's about my character what were you
guys yeah but I would think we think
overall everybody's toughened up a lot
if anything Pope may be getting a little
battle fatigue you might might see
throughout the season but I think
originally it started off as civilians
forced into a situation now I think
everybody's pretty much a soldier or a
warrior or assertive in their own right
in terms of staying alive and all that
kind of stuff so I think everybody's a
little bit more battled battle-hardened
in this particular season
you